a Connecticut man facing charges in
connection with his wife's disappearance
is expected to testify today in an
unrelated civil case Fotis Doulos is
being sued by his wife Jennifer's mother
over more than two and a half million
dollars in what she claims were loans to
his business
Jennifer doulos a mother of five
vanished back in May mola lanky reports
from Hartford Connecticut more than six
months after Jennifer Doulos vanished
from her Connecticut home cameras will
be in court as her husband foetus Doulos
fights accusations that he owes
Jennifer's family millions it's a
horrible horrible situation norm pattice
represents Fotis in the criminal trial
where foetus and his girlfriend Michelle
tritonus have pleaded not guilty to
evidence tampering and hindering
prosecution whatever is said tomorrow
can also be used in any potential
criminal trial does that does that
complicate things does it add more
pressure yes and yes it took it's a
profoundly complicated question
according to the Stanford advocate
Gloria Farber and her late husband sued
Fotis in January 2018 nearly 18 months
before Jennifer disappeared at the time
Fotis and Jennifer were involved in a
bitter divorce battle at the center of
the lawsuit two and a half million
dollars
Fotis was allegedly supposed to pay that
money back to Jennifer's parents after
they invested in his real estate
business
Gloria Farber claims foti still owes her
more than a quarter of that money which
voti says was a gift these commercial
transactions took place years ago we
don't think they shed any light
whatsoever on the criminal allegations
the civil trial comes as police continue
to investigate how Jennifer disappeared
and whether Fotis was responsible good
afternoon
Fotis was in court last month for a
hearing related to Jennifer's
disappearance but would not comment on
the case my only concern on my children
CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clemens
says even though the civil case might
have nothing to do with the criminal one
Doulos is taking a big risk by
testifying a slip of the tongue here
could really be trouble for him in a
criminal case
doulas maintains his innocence in both
the civil and criminal cases in the
civil case a judge will ultimately
decide not a jury in that case is only
expected to take a few days in the
criminal case all parties involved are
under a gag order so it's unclear if
we'll hear anything today related to
that and Anthony we should mention that
both doulos and his girlfriend
trakone us Michele truck owners are out
on bond all right molla so many
unanswered questions than that case
still